I think I read that you said you liked
playing characters that are outsiders
mm-hmm why uh I think it's an
interesting perspective to work with I
mean Outsiders is a broad term so that
could mean a lot but I like playing
characters that challenge people's
perceptions because I think we live in a
world where so much of our perception is
given to it for us this given is given
to us by other people you know it's such
a cliched hipster thing to say but it's
true that you know we're exposed to
commercials all the time and and social
media posts and we tend to surround or
our friend list on social media with
people who agree with us and and you
know a lot of the movies we watch are
made by the same people and controlled
by the same companies and they follow
trends and we're just we're just exposed
to so much media betraying a certain
lifestyle and you can and in today's age
you can choose to surround yourself with
media that that reflects what you find
comfortable and that I think it's it's
very easy to become very locked and what
you believe and so I really like playing
Outsiders because I think it challenges
people's perceptions on what what is
normal or what what life god what life
means no no I
there's a there's a gentleman that wrote
a book I think in the 50s about the
notion of the outsider and and other
people's perceptions the fear some
people have of the outsider and and the
fascination and also the loneliness and
isolation of that outsider and I forgive
me I add the name of the book and the
writer is escaping me but I think it's a
fascinating thing especially now because
we're kind of afraid of anything that's
different and we're taught to fear it
who are some of your favorite outsider
characters and why what do you like
well you know there's Travis Bickel of
course I think the ultimate outsider
movie character like not a good man by
most definitions but I find him
interesting cuz it's easy to just say oh
he's just a crazy guy but you know it's
like he I think that that character is a
reflection of a society that produced
him you know it's like imagine that you
live in that city at that time and
you're in this car and you're just
separated from the city by glass and
metal and you're driving passing and we
talked about you know the pimps and the
hustlers and all these different people
and you know I think about the people
getting to his cab late at night you
know I like businessmen cheating on
their wives with with different girls or
like you know there's that one character
who's the opposite of the husband trying
to find his wife he says I'm gonna shoot
her in the Fate in the know he says
when it's rooted in the with
a 44 magnum pistol and you know he lives
in this right little apartment by
himself and this warming hive of people
and and you know he doesn't have a lot
of money so he you know he goes to like
those pornographic movie houses and you
know he takes that girl - that
pornographic movie house and it sags I
think he actually in his mind thought it
was a good idea for a date I think
because I like how it doesn't really
tell you a lot about his past he says
he's a Vietnam vet some people wonder
whether he is the screenwriter says that
he is yeah and I think it's easy to just
look at him as this crazy person but you
gotta ask like am I just a few steps
away from being Travis Bickle like what
if I was put alone an apartment in a
ratty part of town for that amount of
time and if I was cut off from people
and if I'd seen what he'd seen so is it
is it fascinating to see someone that
the masses would say they're weird or
they're bad but if you really is bad I'm
not saying you saw Asher but but maybe
there's others in varying degrees where
if you sort of looked at the timeline of
their life you could see why they got to
that
point and maybe have more empathy but
instead most people put up the shield of
fear and you're more fascinated by
peeling back those layers yeah yeah you
know it's like I am and not just that
type of outside are different Outsiders
too but I guess I'm a type of guy who
let's say if someone gets bitten by a
rabid dog most people tend to feel bad
for the guy and I feel bad for the guy
too it'll get me wrong but I also tend
to feel bad for the rabid dog because
they're a very they're very they're very
few genuine sociopaths in the world like
people who are just born with no
morality whatsoever you know and I think
it's it's hard to because I think you
know I'm not I wouldn't go as far as to
say that I'm a biological determinist I
wouldn't go that far but I think at the
end of the day we are physical systems
where we're a collection of cells and
like if I touched like a hot poker that
is a bunch of molecules and energies it
sends a reaction to these physical cells
you know this whole universe we live in
is a physical universe it's full of
actions and reactions and you know we
are bana muls and I think people don't
like being told that there are animals
because it ruins their kind of illusions
of being this effervescent spirit that's
in complete control of their life you
know like I am a individual and I
control my destiny and like you do I
don't think you can control your destiny
nearly as well unless you're very aware
of your base kind of cognitive biases
and your base instincts you know like
and I think depending on the physical
environment that you're in
you know people react to that so I think
if we got to be aware of this and really
be aware of like the the type of media
we consume or the type of message that
we're sending and and I just think
that's the only way that we can really
make people change or is if we're aware
of what created them you know cuz I
think people like to treat these people
like bogeyman like it's easy to treat a
suicide bomber like just some crazy
person who hates people and yeah maybe
he hates people he's a bad guy he's a
bad guy but a lot but maybe but you know
you got to look back and if this many
people are
are creating these actions and doing
what they do that that are willing to
give up their lives what they believe is
a cause obviously something has put them
into a rather desperate position so we
got to examine what caused that
situation in the first place rather than
just treating it like a like a thing
like something that can be like we treat
evil like it's just this thing that can
be killed we can just make it go away by
killing it so rather than changing the
circumstances that bring it about do you
think people can write a script for
their own life and and become and this
is such like a cliche but do we
determine our own fate and in doing that
can you somehow relate it to acting I
think we can if you try to make yourself
aware like really study you know study
all sorts of different areas you know
study psychology but then again study
the different branches and and and see
the different ideas but not just
psychology or like you know study
history to see what people have done and
see what the results of that were and
see different perspectives not just one
and again I think this be aware of the
fact that you are a little creature you
know that is is given certain instincts
by what you were exposed to and it's
then question yourself you know I mean
be confident yourself but question
yourself and I think in the way that
that relates to acting you always got to
be perfectly aware of the physical
reality of your character I don't think
that necessarily means like what's your
characters favorite colour or like you
know what was your character's mom like
but if it's in the script but if they
live in a house and it says their house
is like this well what does that say
about them you know like if they if they
if they go to it they're like a
construction worker well what are the
physical realities of being a
construction worker you know and how
does that relate to what the point of
the story is you know like because
writer chose that for a reason to make
them a construction worker so how does
that relate to the point that they're
trying to make
you